We have just hit 2100,
We are now facing very serious opponents,
And for those who have been following the speedrun and kind of watching it evolve, we've
basically hit a rating where opening theory has become ultra important,
So what you'll see in the last couple of videos is that we spend a good amount of the time
we have during the game and the time that we analyze actually focusing on the opening
theory and trying to get it right,
Because if you're at 2100 standard on chess,com, like at this point you have to have a very
well put together opening repertoire in which you basically know your main lines,
And the entire premise of the speedrun is that my explanations as well as the analysis
is made to the level at which we're at,
So if you're a newer chess player or if you're a beginner, hopefully you'll still find helpful
things within my explanations,
But just realize that I'm trying to level the explanations at the rating range in which
we currently are located,
So having clarified that, let's throw ourselves into the pool,
And we probably will have black,
We had white in our last speedrun game,
It was an Alepyn, which our opponent played the E65 variation, was a pretty quick game,
Let's see what the chess gods have in store for us here,
There we go,
We have white again against Kazeo 2088,
And as usual, we begin with one E4,
Let's see what our opponent faces us with,
And we have a French, which I think, believe it or not, we have not faced yet in this speedrun,
Don't quote me on that,
I might be wrong,
Obviously, our response is D4, and here we are already at an early crossroads,
Now the line that I have recommended in previous speedruns is the advanced French, but not
just a regular advanced French, but rather the Niemcewicz variation of the advanced
French, where you go E5, black plays C5, and then you don't play the sort of automatic
move C3,
Instead, you actually develop your knight,
It's a super counterintuitive line if you've never seen it before, because white voluntarily
gives away the pawn chain and allows C takes D4, and there's like a deep positional underpinning
to the Niemcewicz variation that makes it, I think, a very dangerous line for the unprepared
player,
But since this is a more opening theory minded speedrun, I want to play the line that I am
most comfortable with personally, the line that I've played for most of my life, and
that is the tarash variation, which is characterized by the move knight to D2,
So if you know nothing about the French, then very briefly white has a couple of ways to
meet the move,
D5, the most natural of white's responses and the most popular move is knight to C3,
That leads to incredibly theoretical variations, and that's something we don't want to touch
with a 10 foot pull,
There's also the exchange variation, which we also don't want to touch with a 10 foot
pull,
I think the tarash is a great line because it straddles the bridge between not being
too theoretical, but also having that venom which can allow you to really crush a player
who's not incredibly well prepared,
In response to the tarash, black has two main continuations,
The one that appears more commonly in modern day grandmaster chess is C5, and I'll talk
a little bit about it after the game,
The sort of more traditional French spirited move is knight to F6, and in response we push
E5, and we get kind of the advanced French structure,
Now the main line is bishop to D3, we bring our bishop out to the most natural square,
black plays C5, and here in fact we do play the move C3,
And you shouldn't think of this as an advanced variation,
This is the pawn structure that you will find in a lot of different French lines, but the
advanced variation has very, very different piece configurations for both sides,
So there's actually very little in common between this line of the tarash and the advanced
French, by which I mean 3E5,
And in this position, white is at a further crossroads,
We have to defend the d4 pawn, and we can do it in two main ways,
The traditional move is to bring the knight out to E2, and there's a lot of positional
details that kind of stand behind the reason why a certain move is played, or we choose
one particular way of defending the d4 pawn,
But the move that I have always played, and I've played this with great success, the more
tactical line is knight G to F3,
So 10 to 15 years ago, maybe even 20 years ago, this was still a newer move that was
catching French players off guard, and there was a period where even the strongest GMs
and noted French experts were struggling tremendously against the move knight GF3,
But now this is a very well-known line, it's still less popular than knight to E2, but
in my opinion, it's more dangerous, and it's easier to learn and to play for the sort of
intermediate player,
So black responds with one of the many possible continuations, just kind of a regular developing
move, bishop to E7, and we do the same,
We castle king side, and here black is at a further crossroads,
There is a super tactical line where black plays G5,
I'm really hoping that we face that line in this game, because that will allow me to illustrate
a lot of the juicy ideas that white has in this variation of the tarash,
But French players who aren't too familiar with the knight GF3 variation often resort
to the more natural continuation, which is just a castle king side, and in that position
white has sort of a small but very stable advantage, and white's play in that line is
pretty intuitive and rather unremarkable,
So our opponent is taking a little bit of time,
Don't misinterpret my words,
The tarash is still a very, very theoretical line, and you still have to know a lot of
theory if you want to play this line successfully for white, but you still can't compare the
amount of theory in the tarash to the amount of theory in three knight C3, which I would
never recommend, even to an advanced player, because the time investment that you have
to put in to play knight C3 successfully I just think is not realistic for most people
with a job and a family,
I think knight D2, again, kind of strikes that balance,
It gives you a serious chance to fight for the advantage without being ridiculously theoretical,
There's a lot to know, but you can definitely learn this, and you can play the tarash very
successfully,
So we get back to this position, and we're facing the move A5, which is yet another of
black's kind of top-rate continuations,
This move is very, very common in this line, and it's a more positional way for black to
treat this line,
Black is kind of grabbing space on the queen side,
Black is also preventing, well, knight B3 was impossible anyway because of C4,
Black's main idea is to drive this pawn down to A4 and make it very difficult for white
to reshuffle his pieces on the queen side, right?
That pawn on A4 really clamps down on some key queen side squares, and it makes it hard
for us to play B3,
It covers the B3 square, and often black accompanies the move A5 with the follow of queen to B6,
which exerts even more pressure on the D4 pawn,
So there's many ways that we could meet the move A5, but the most natural one, and the
one that I've played for most of my life, is just to play A4 and to freeze the A5 pawn
in its tracks,
I think this is a very unpleasant move for most French players because we're preventing
black from achieving their main aim, that is to drive the pawn to A4,
So once again, we just shut all that garbage down, we play A4,
I've had this position in numerous over-the-board games, and here black plays pawn takes D4,
Our opponent displays a good knowledge of opening theory, the point of this sequence
is that by provoking us into playing A4, black has created an outpost for his knight or his
bishop, but typically his knight on B4,
And we're probably going to see our opponent play the move knight to B4,
And I think one thing that has to happen as you climb the raiding ladder is you have to
have a more nuanced positional perspective on whatever situation you're in,
So I think a newer player would see the B4 square and say, well, this is really unpleasant,
right?
Black can play knight to B4 and attack our bishop, and that's a huge outpost for the
knight,
But the outpost on B4 is just one of many, many components in this super rich position,
Some of those components favor black, but a lot of those components actually favor white,
So for one thing, we have the equivalent outpost on B5,
And it's true that it is a lot harder for us to get a knight to B5, because for us to
get a knight to B5, we would have to burn three tempi,
And you actually do see white playing the move knight B1 followed by knight C3 and sometimes
knight B5 in this line,
And the reason that you have these tempi to burn is that the center is closed,
And as I've clarified on many occasions, when the center is closed, you typically have more
time to do what it is that you want to do, whatever it is,
Like any maneuver, any plan, you have more time to achieve it because there's kind of
less going on,
And as long as you can keep your center defended, you've got quite a bit more time than you
would with a wide open center,
But I don't really want to play knight B1,
I don't want to commit to a particular mode of play,
I want to wait for black to put his cards on the table,
And in these positions, white has quite a few moves that are non-committal, but that
improve your position and that set ourselves up for success in the event that the center
opens up,
And if you're a more habitual French player with either side, you should know that there
is one idea that you should always be prepared for,
Like when we look at this position, we've talked about ways in which black can attack
the d4 pawn,
And in reality, there's only one such way black can play queen to B6,
But you can also attack this pawn chain from the other side, and it's a lot more common
across all French lines for black to play the move f6,
This opens up the center, it opens up the f-file,
And whatever we do, we need to be prepared in the event that black decides to play f6,
And so a very, very good way for us to do that is just to situate the rook on e1,
Might seem like a pointless move because we're putting the rook on a closed file, but in
light of my explanation, you should begin to understand how it helps us prepare against
f6,
We're discouraging that move quite strongly because we take on f6,
And not only does the rook then find itself on an open file, but the pawn on e6 is right
in its crosshairs,
And if after f6, e takes f6, black is forced to take back with a knight, then black weakens
his grip on the e5 square, and we can use that juicy, juicy square as a big outpost
for our knight,
So black plays knight b4, our opponent obviously does not resist the temptation, and forces
us to decide on a spot for our bishop,
So there's a couple of ways that we could approach this,
We could stick our bishop on the equivalent outpost on b5,
But I don't like that move as much because I like to play this line in a very tactical
attacking manner,
And so I really like the placement of this bishop on the b1 h7 diagonal,
Why do I say that?
Because, well, the bishop is targeting the h7 pawn,
So there's Greek gift sacrifices that could happen,
Once we bring more pieces to the king side, that bishop is going to be an invaluable asset
as we transition our attention from the center to the king side,
And so therefore, the move that I like is bishop back to b1,
Nothing wrong with making a retreating move,
The bishop is just as effective here as it was on d3,
It's still aiming on h7,
And one additional idea that this move makes possible for later is rook a1 to a3,
We could actually lift the rook right under the knight's nose,
Because in playing knight b4, black has cut his control over the a3 square,
So in a future where, let's say, we move the knight away from f3, we could play rook a3
and quickly involve the rook into the attack,
So if you're looking at this from the perspective of space, it may seem like black is doing
fantastic again,
Like, he's played knight b4 and he's pushed our bishop to the back rank,
But that's why bishops exist,
They're super long range pieces,
And I'm telling you, we're only a couple of moves away from being able to launch a mating
attack,
And I'm telling you this very, very accurately,
I feel like we are only a couple of moves away from smashing through on the king side,
which could be hard to conceptualize,
But hopefully, the course of the game, if it goes in our favor, will allow me to demonstrate
that,
OK, so our opponent continues to think,
Our opponent has a couple of issues that they still have to solve,
Obviously, there's this famous French bishop on c8, which still doesn't have a home,
Most people here, I think, have the inclination to play b6 and try to deploy the bishop via
a6,
But even if black does all that, that bishop on a6 is still kind of out of the action,
OK, instead our opponent plays knight to b8, which is a regrouping that I've seen before,
I guess our opponent is heading for c6 with the knight and probably wants to leave the
d7 square open for the bishop,
But this is where we start assembling our pieces, not into like full attacking position,
but we basically assemble our pieces in the general vicinity of the king side,
And as crazy as it may seem for me to say this, we're already preparing for a mating
attack,
So there's one particular maneuver that you have to know in order to play this position
successfully,
And most people in the chat are indicating this move, which is pretty impressive to me,
And that is the move knight f1,
If you play the Ruy Lopez, really if you're a 1e4 player, you should be familiar with
this maneuver because it's virtually universal across a large amount of different openings,
The Ruy Lopez is one of them,
And this opening, the Taras French, is another,
It is incredibly common for white to maneuver the knight over to g3,
Now why do we do that?
What exactly is the knight doing on g3?
Well, the reasoning is pretty simple,
First of all, we're kind of unclogging the pipes a little bit,
The knight on d2 is in the way of essentially all of our pieces,
It's in the way of the queen,
It's in the way of the dark squared bishop,
On g3, it's completely out of the way of the other minor pieces,
But the knight can itself be used as a major attacking weapon,
We can jump from g3 over to h5, and you can already see that certain sacrifices are starting
to loom in the air,
Like knight takes g7 could be possible,
If black plays g6 in response, we could stick the knight on f6, and sometimes that move
is very strong, even if it sacrifices a pawn, because it gives us complete and total dark
squared domination,
So already in this position, we have multiple ways that we can continue the attack,
The rook a3 move that I had mentioned earlier is a viable candidate move,
We could set that rook up in position so that when the knights move out of the way, it can
jump into g3,
But another very typical idea that you'll see in a lot of French books and a lot of
attacking manuals is the move h2, h4,
And if this move works out successfully, then after the game, I can show you countless examples
of this move leading to a decisive attack, again, across many different openings,
That's the beauty of the attack that we're about to unroll,
I really feel like all of these moves are essentially universal, so your eyes shouldn't
glaze over just because you're not a 1e4 player or you don't face the French a lot,
These are important ideas for you to conceptualize, because they form the underpinning of successful
attacking chess,
Now, what the heck is the point of h4?
And it's not what you might think,
Of course, we can advance this pawn two squares to h6, but that would actually serve to close
the king side up,
That is the last thing that we want, because it would allow black to play g6, and then
it would be very, very hard to unclog the kind of reverse triangle pawn formation that
black would have set up,
A much more common follow-up to h4 is, of course, knight f3 to g5, so we're creating
a stronghold for the knight to jump to g5, and once the knight jumps to g5, the diagonal
now opens up for the queen to leap into h5, so you can see how quickly the pieces start
coming into position, and there's often a point at which you have to sacrifice something,
For example, if we're allowed to play knight g5, and black responds with h6, as you should
already understand, the point isn't then just to jump back to h3,
It's often to leave the knight on g5, so that if black takes it with the h pawn, the h file
opens up, so a great follow-up would be, for instance, queen d1 to h5, or even queen d1
to g4, targeting the g7 pawn and x-raying the king,
Now, all of this is great, you might be looking at this and saying, well, I get it, we want
to go knight g5, but what happens if black takes the pawn on h4?
And I will be honest, I haven't decided yet on a specific response to that move, but this
is something I'll address in a little bit more depth after the game, assuming our opponent
doesn't take that pawn, but there's a couple of important things to understand before we
even address the actual point of the sacrifice, and the first is that in these types of middle
games, a single pawn almost never decides the outcome of the game,
Almost all of the pieces are still on the board, and so sacking an h pawn is not something
that you should think of in the same category as a queen sacrifice, or like a piece sacrifice,
right?
You should distinguish in your head pawn sacrifices from piece sacrifices, and I know that sounds
very banal, but a lot of players, they lump that into the same category, like they think
of h4 as a huge commitment, and if the attack doesn't work out, we lose,
And on the vast majority of levels, that's absolutely not the case,
So one very simple thing that we could do after bishop takes h4 would have just been
to take the bishop and claim that we have the bishop pair and dark square control,
So it's really not such a big investment or commitment to where you have to have a clear
understanding of what you're doing if black takes the pawn,
We'll talk about that more after the game, because black has taken the game in a completely
different direction, he's played f6, which I think is a pretty adequate response to h4,
Black tries to open up the center and make it harder for us to concentrate our forces
on the king side,
Well, we don't have too much of a choice here,
We don't want to allow black to be the one to take on e5,
We should do it from a position of strength,
So let's start by playing e takes f6,
It would be great if we could play queen d1 to h5 here, unfortunately that is illegal,
And now we reach a critical moment,
Here we have to be very concrete and very accurate because we've got a weakness on t4
and we have to keep that pawn in mind,
That's not just any pawn,
If we give that pawn up and black takes it with the bishop, then the f2 pawn will be
in the crosshairs of the rook and the bishop as well,
So knight g5 might come to mind as a very tempting move,
But in response to knight g5, black will probably go h6,
And if we just blindly throw our pieces onto the king side, we might very well end up at
a dead end because black will take on d4 and generate pretty massive counterplay based
on an attack on f2,
So if we do play knight g5, we actually have to calculate some variations there,
Some of you are pointing out knight g5, h6, and then knight takes e6,
But then black plays bishop takes e6, rook takes e6, and bishop takes d4,
And again, it appears that white is at a dead end because black has major, major pressure
on f2,
Then h4 is also going to be hanging,
That doesn't seem to be really in the spirit of the line,
So I'm going to take a little moment here and think about our candidate moves,
What's interesting is that we haven't really made any tactical commitments, right?
We haven't committed to playing sacrificially or even playing tactically,
We could take this in a positional direction,
Because if we think about the move f6 in sort of a positional framework, the main drawback
of this move is that it creates a massive hole on e5,
And this hole could be used later on in the game as an outpost for our knight,
So you might say, well, what are we waiting for?
Let's go knight e5,
But if you go knight e5 too soon, this goes back to something that we discussed in an
earlier game, which is that you don't want to occupy a weak square with a pawn,
You typically want to occupy it with a piece,
And after knight takes e5, we would have to recapture with the pawn,
And we would also give up h4,
So you might say, well, how do we prepare the move knight e5?
Let's play bishop f4,
And that would be a totally viable move,
But I think a more challenging move for black would actually be bishop c1 to g5,
This is a more active way to try to remove one of black's critical defenders on the e5
square,
And this is a typical concept,
So notice that we played h4 with a tactical aim in mind,
We wanted to checkmate black with knight g5,
But we're actually using that move for positional purposes,
And this is the flexibility that I talk about really often, which is necessary if you want
to thrive at a high level,
You can't get fixated on one particular goal,
OK, black did something unexpected,
So we change our frame of thinking,
And now we're playing very positionally for control over the e5 square,
What is black likely to do here?
Well, if black plays bishop takes g5, I actually think we could have some really, really cool
tactics there based on a Greek gift sacrifice with bishop takes h7, believe it or not,
And we'll explore that after the game because I don't think black is going to take our bishop,
But it essentially functions like a regular Greek gift,
Bishop g5, bishop h7, king h7, we recapture on g5 with check,
And after king g8, our queen drives into h5,
And I feel like the attack is unstoppable, much like it is in a regular Greek gift sacrifice,
So what happens if black doesn't take on g5?
Well, the move I'm expecting is h6,
I think this is going to be the instinct of most 2,000 players,
And then, of course, we play bishop takes bishop,
Black will probably recapture with the queen, which I think is the most natural way of recapturing,
And then I think would be a great time to increase our control over the e5 square by
applying the rook lifts that I had talked about earlier, like rook a3, rook e3,
And again, when I had mentioned this rook lift many moves ago, I mentioned it in a tactical
context,
I mentioned it in the context of trying to get the rook, let's say, to the g file,
And again, we're repurposing a tactical idea into a positional idea,
We're using the rook lift to increase our control over this key central square on e5,
And we're going to try to strangle black positionally rather than checkmate him tactically if h6
happens,
Now, you might hear all of that and say, OK, this makes sense,
But haven't we seriously weakened our king side with h4?
And h4 is far from a serious weakening of the king side,
It really isn't a big deal that we pushed the h-bond, because we still have the core
of our king side pawn formation, and our king is still perfectly safe,
Queen c7, OK, that's a decent move, I think, by our opponent, which doesn't seem to do
all that much,
I guess it unpins the bishop, but it's not like the bishop has all that much mobility
to begin with,
And I think there's no need for us to take on f6 and allow black's rook to jump into
a pretty good square on f6,
I think we should proceed with our plan as if black didn't do anything,
And we already know what a great way to improve our position is,
I think we should play rook a3,
And we start playing this kind of general waiting game, where both of us are trying
to improve our position, and eventually things are going to clarify,
Something is going to happen very, very soon, because the tension has reached a peak,
But for the time being, we can just chill, because everything is nicely defended,
One annoying aspect of this position is that we can't put our queen on d3 or c2,
That would be incredible,
That would be sexy,
That would be like the best battery of all time,
So we have to give some credit to the placement of this knight on b4,
It is restricting the mobility of our queen, but we can do without it,
And our bishop is still an excellent piece, because it's still creating constant headaches
for black on the h7 square,
The rook a3, lifting the rook up to e3, and you shouldn't think of that move as increasing
the pressure on the pawn, because the pawn on e6 is actually pretty well defended by
the bishop,
So unless we attack it with a minor piece, that pawn is not going to be winnable,
Instead, we're increasing our control over that stronghold on e5, and one day we hope
to occupy that square with the knight,
We don't know when that day will arrive,
We don't know if that's ultimately going to be what wins us the game,
But by doubling rooks on the e-file, we're actually making it very difficult for black
to breathe,
So already black is, I think, starting to run out of helpful moves,
When that happens, usually people try to force things, so I'm expecting h6,
And in response to h6, we probably will take the bishop on f6,
Another thing that you should be aware of is that if we play bishop takes bishop, we
should not be afraid of black taking back with the pawn,
Because that fixes one problem, right, of the e5 score, but it creates like 50 others,
If black plays g takes f6, the king is going to be wide open, and the pawn on h6 is going
to be a sitting duck, and we can simply target it by playing queen to d2 in that position,
You should always remember the possibility of leaping into h5 with your knight, right?
If black ever brings the king up to g7, that knight from g3 can jump into h5 and force
the king right back to g8,
Okay, so obviously black plays rook e8, we play rook e3, and the kind of waiting game
continues,
This is where things are about to get very exciting,
So Lamamu asks, what if black plays e5?
I haven't calculated this move, but I'll bet you a silver dollar that e5 is never going
to work in this position,
How do I know that?
Because black's position is so riddled with holes and so passive, that opening up the
center like that just isn't going to work,
In response to e5, we can, for instance, take on f6, and after rook takes f6, pawn takes
e5, we literally have more defenders on the e5 square than black has attackers, so it
just loses a pawn,
So you should, I mean, e5 is a legitimate idea in the French, but in this particular
situation, we're so much better prepared for the center to be open, that this isn't something
that's even on my radar,
Queen d6,
So to our opponent's credit, he is sort of maintaining his composure, which means we
need to turn the pressure dial up a little bit more,
Now we can make moves belonging to two categories here,
We can continue playing like general Russian schoolboy moves, and that would involve queen
to d2, or even a move like b3, you'll sometimes see GMs play to shore up the a4 pawn, kind
of pass the ball back to black,
But I feel personally that the time has come for us to take more concrete, more decisive
action, because we've essentially improved our position to the maximum,
And there is one move, there is one asset that we haven't exploited yet, which is of
course the knight jump to h5, and this is what we just talked about,
I think this would be a great opportunity for us to throw that move in,
Why are we playing knight h5 here?
Because you might look at this and say, well, I don't see what this threatens,
Well, this doesn't threaten anything tactical,
We're not threatening to win a piece, but what we are threatening to do is completely
ruin black's pawn cover by taking this bishop and forcing black to take back with a pawn,
In particular, this is bad for black because then the bishop can also jump into h6, and
the dark squares around black's king are going to be completely indefensible,
So that's like an unthinkable option for black,
We're essentially forcing black to take on g5, and we already know that this trade, particularly
in that version, is super favorable for us,
A, because the e5 square will then be under our complete control, and B, because tactically
after bishop takes g5, we could consider either a Greek gift sacrifice on h7, which honestly
is a little bit less appealing to me, because the h5 square is occupied by the knight, or
in that situation, we could have just recaptured with the pawn and then stuck a knight on e5,
King h8, our opponent calls our bluff, isn't afraid of knight takes f6, and actually prepares
for that eventuality by opening up the g8 square for the rook,
So he's sort of preemptively tucking the king away so that knight takes f6 comes with a
little bit less force, which means that we should kind of consider changing our plans,
I no longer think knight takes f6 is the best way to squeeze the most out of the position,
because after gf, it's actually not clear who that transformation favors, because once
black puts a rook on g8, guess what?
Our king isn't the safest piece either, and black could generate some counterplay,
So now I think would be a good time to ask ourselves, do we want to do something tactical?
Do we want to try to checkmate black on the king side, or do we want to continue improving
our position?
Let me think about this for just a second, because this is an important moment,
I have an idea that I think is a good move, but I have to double check,
Yeah, I'm pretty sure that the move I have in mind actually might win the game,
So remember that I mentioned earlier that when we have a weak square, we don't want
to occupy it with a pawn,
Well, there's an asterisk and a caveat to that, right?
Because everything I say of that form is not a rule, right?
It's a general guideline, and the situation on the board could change your approach to
that guideline,
So I think that the best move here and the best way to squeeze the most out of the position
is in fact to play knight to e5,
Now this is based on both a positional and tactical observation,
Tactically it's easy to observe that if black takes with the knight, yeah, we take back
with the pawn, but this is a fork,
This forks the queen and bishop and wins a minor piece,
But what about bishop takes e5?
Well, in that case, we take back with the pawn, and I didn't calculate any further
than that,
I calculated up to that position, and I concluded that the presence of two minor pieces on perfect
attacking positions, the possibility of us completing our rook lift to g3, and the ease
with which we can involve our queen in the attack basically means that black's situation
on the king's side is going to be completely hopeless, and I already see like two or three
different types of sacrifices that just end the game straight away,
So for instance, after bishop e5, d, e, let's say black drops the queen back to c7, a very
easy sacrifice would be knight takes g7, replacing the knight with the queen, and that's a position
which should kind of intuitively be clear to you, and it doesn't even have to be clear
to you because we're going to reach it in the game,
Our opponent is kind of so focused on winning the battle of the e5 square that I think he's
kind of missed the forest for the trees,
Now he thinks, okay, finally I can breathe a sigh of relief,
The rooks are kind of pointlessly located on the e-file, and now it's I think dawning
on him that we once again switch our attention from the center to the king side, and we again
switch from positional thinking to direct tactical thinking to checkmate mode,
And we're only 22 moves in,
It feels like we've been playing forever, but you know, we've barely exited the opening
queen to c5, and now it's time for us to think concretely to calculate and try to find the
fastest path to checkmate,
So the simplest pattern here is I think to play knight takes g7,
The idea is twofold,
First of all, we're shattering the pawn protection of black's king, which will make it easier
to deliver checkmate, but second of all, we're forcibly removing the knight from h5 so that
the queen can take the knight's place, and queen h5 in that resulting position just looks
absolutely crushing,
I really think that we don't need to calculate that line any further,
If that's not crushing, then I quit chess,
Like that has to be crushing,
Maybe we have a nicer checkmate, maybe there is a more precise way to win the game, but
in the context of a rapid game, you shouldn't get bogged down with trying to find the perfect
solution,
Once you see something that looks really, really juicy and relatively noncommittal,
because we're only sacking a minor piece, right?
This isn't like a queen sack,
You can safely go for it,
So no, I'm like literally 100 million percent sure that this is unstoppable checkmate,
Black has to take the knight, otherwise we play queen h5 anyway, and this is resignable,
The attack essentially ends before it begins,
Now I know that there were a lot of concepts in this game that I touched on either briefly
or superficially, and that's because we've never faced the French before and I've never
played the tariff before, which is why I couldn't talk about everything, but hopefully the general
course of the game made sense to you and the reasoning behind almost every move,
The king is in shambles and it's instructive to see how all of black's pieces are kind
of stuck in no man's land,
The b4 square was once significant, but now it's completely pointless,
Nothing's happening on the queen side, and of course now we should take a moment and
realize that bishop f6 check I think would be a very serious inaccuracy and a move that
would appeal to a lot of beginners, and the reason is because black had sacked the exchange
on f6, and that's the last thing that we want,
The last thing we want is a situation in which we're suddenly out of attackers and black's
king is close to escaping via the center, and in general when you're trying to checkmate
the king on one side of the board, you should keep one eye open for the king's possible
escape routes, because a lot of attacks have been refuted or put to death by the king just
like suddenly escaping toward the center, and if black's king were not on g7 but let's
say on c7, white would be completely lost,
So the attack is situational, it's based on where black's king is and we have to make
sure that it remains firmly locked on the king's side, and that's a good reason for
us to keep our dark squared bishop alive,
If nothing else, that bishop holds the king's escape route via e7 under lock and key, like
even if black's king were somehow on f7 here, it would not be able to escape via e7 and
d8 because of the presence of this dark squared bishop, if that makes sense,
So the game is over, I mean we have a lot more than we even need on the king's side,
but let's try to be precise because our opponent is defending well knight c2,
Okay so a couple of things to understand here, I think that there are a million ways for
us to win the game, ranging from really simple moves like even like rook e1 to c1,
I think would be a good example of a banal move that wins the game because it adds a
second attacker and opens up a second front on the queen's side, but here I would try
to be a little bit more forcing in view of our time pressure, and here I would actually
start calculating variations,
So bishop f6 check comes to mind, and I think is a much better version here than it was
on the previous move,
Here's how that goes,
After bishop f6 check, black has to take, then we play e takes f6 check, and in that
resulting position black has a choice, either he can take the pawn or he can duck away to
h8,
If he takes the pawn on f6, we have checkmate in two moves,
We can slide the queen over to g5, king drops back to f7 and then rook f3 is literally checkmate,
If after bishop f6, rook takes f6, e f6, the king ducks back to h8, I think in that position
we have a very simple move, which rather than getting too fixated on the checkmate just
wins a bunch of material,
Does anybody see what move I'm referring to?
And we're actually going to reach this position, assuming our opponent doesn't take on f6,
And this is another very instructive concept within the general realm of attacking chess,
which is not to get too transfixed on ending the attack with checkmate,
This is a huge, huge reason why a lot of attacks fail is you fall in love with the prospect
of delivering checkmate, and you don't realize that one way of concluding a successful attack
is just to win a bunch of material,
I've talked about this a lot in other videos and other speedrun games, and this is a great
example of that, right?
It's very easy here,
You have two minutes, less than two minutes,
You start calculating, you're like f7, maybe a queen sac on h7,
All of that is totally unnecessary,
Maybe there is checkmate, but I see a move which I know for a fact ends the game on the
spot because it wins the knight on c2, and then we're going to be up in exchange, and
we're going to have this decisive attack,
So this isn't some sort of weak man's attacking move,
I think this is probably even the best move according to the engine, as you'll find,
And one other important observation is that the knight is actually pinned, not in the
traditional way, but if it takes the rook, we have queen takes h7 checkmate, otherwise
black would have a way to give away the queen for two pieces, and the game would continue,
Now we obviously play bishop takes c2, and we kind of enter the final stage where we
just need to make a couple more accurate moves and finish off the attack,
The most pleasant type of attack is one in which you actually are up material, because
then you don't feel the pressure of having to convert the attack in a certain span of
time,
So what's the easiest way to end this game?
Well, any time a pawn is moved, you have to briefly assess what squares it opens up for
your pieces,
There are two moves that win on the spot,
The first is to complete the rook lift with rook g3, but the more thematic move is queen
to g6,
How do you see this move?
Well, you should have been aware of this idea really for the entirety of the game, and I
think it's kind of fitting that our early decision to put the bishop on b1 rather than
f1 or b5 bears fruit at the very end of the game,
We actually end the game by finally being able to set up this battery, and in the event
of queen g8, this is just made in two,
So a simple game, a pretty straightforward attack, nothing crazy, nothing special, but
this is how to kill the French, essentially,
So I will not be able to talk about, A, even one one-hundredth of the theory of this variation,
and B, about all of the key ideas in this structure, because this is a very complicated
structure, but I'll try to give you a general picture of what we want to achieve with white
and what you need to study if you want to reach a good command of the tariff variation,
which has brought me a lot of success,
So previously, in previous speedruns, I recommended the Nimzavitch variation,
I still stand by it, I still think it's a great line, and I'm trying to give you a choice,
And in this position, c3 is the traditional advanced variation, also very good, but the
line that we played previously is knight to f3, and the basic idea is that if black takes
on d4, you don't recapture on d4, you aim for quick development and control over key
squares in the center,
You're basically trying to keep this pawn alive and make sure that this pawn seriously
clamps down on black's development,
But at a higher level, this line is considered to be a little bit dubious, and if black knows
how to play against it, white's not contending for an advantage,
In fact, white is struggling for equality if black plays this very precisely, which
is why at a 2100 plus level, I like the tarash, 92,
So black has two main continuations here, and then there's a couple of sidelines,
The main continuations, the ones that you'll encounter by far the most often, are knight
f6 and then the immediate central strike c5,
And in response to c5, I can direct you to Wesley Soh's chessable course, 1e4, where
I think he has some of the best analysis of this variation that you'll find anywhere,
So if you really want to go deep and learn the tarash, you should go to Wesley's chessable
course,
Now, as a caveat, Wesley, I'm pretty sure, recommends the more traditional 92 variation,
which is a great line, but this is more positional, whereas I prefer to play more tactically,
so you can kind of pick and choose from Wesley's course,
Now, as an elevator summary of what c5 is all about, here the move I recommend is knight
g3, aiming for quick development and making sure that both of your central pawns are covered,
And there's a pretty staggering amount of theory here,
The main continuation nowadays is cxd4, knight takes d4, and now knight to c6 is considered
the sort of the most straightforward continuation,
Here you bring your bishop out to b5,
Black responds with bishop d7, you play knight takes c6, and you reach like another very
typical kind of pawn structure that you have to understand and know in order to play the
tarash successfully,
In fact, black can play bishop takes c6 here, but more common in recent times is pawn takes
c6,
I faced this pretty recently in one of my last tournaments,
The bishop drops back to d3, and I feel like this position is just much easier to play
for white, especially if you're like a newer to intermediate player than it is for black,
We will skip the analysis of this line and kind of leave it to the next time that we
face the French,
In this analysis, I'd like to focus on knight f6, because there's more than enough to talk
about here,
The sidelines, by the way, are dxc4, which is the Rubenstein variation, and this is a
line that is favorited by a couple of French experts, including Georg Meyer, the German
GM who's basically played this for his whole life,
This is nothing to be afraid of,
Again, black can fight for equality here with like super, super accurate play, but for newer
players, white's position is just much, much easier to play, and this is not something
that is going to stop you from playing the charge successfully,
And then there's like a couple of third-rate lines, like knight to c6, I think this is
called the Guimard line,
White responds with knight f3, and this line can get very tactical as well,
And then at some point, bishop e7 was really popular as well, but most likely if black
plays bishop e7 and you respond with knight to f3, this line is likely to transpose into
a version, actually into the game continuation,
Like after knight f6, you play e5, then you play bishop d3, and we literally have the
exact position from the game,
So black can start with bishop e7,
The only main deviation is that black can go c5 in this position, which leads to a fundamentally
different variation,
Here you have to study some theory after pawn takes e5,
So remember that yes, there is a lot to know, but all of these positions are very difficult
to play for black, and if black plays the French, he also has to know a ton,
And in almost any situation where both sides are on their own, this is my central contention,
I think it's much easier to play with white if you're acquainted with basic ideas and
basic structures than it is to play black in most of these taros variations,
So hopefully I haven't lost you yet,
Let's go with knight f6, knight fd7, bishop d3,
These moves are basically automatic,
There is a sideline here where black plays b6, again, it's nothing to write home about,
For the purposes of this analysis, we'll stick to knight c6, knight gf3,
So a couple of words about traditional ways of playing this for black,
The most important line that you should absolutely know if you want to play this successfully
with white is the move queen to b6,
So queen b6 is the old main line,
It is, I think, the most testing continuation at sort of an intermediate level,
And the reason for that is that white should be okay with a pawn sacrifice here,
And this is part of the appeal of playing the knight f3 variation to me,
But this is why more positional players like to go knight e2 here, because if black plays
queen b6 in this position, who can tell me what additional resource white has that allows
us to protect the d4 pawn and avoid sacrificing it?
Who can spot the difference?
Yeah, so in this position, we have knight f3, and now we have enough defenders on this
pawn,
We have three defenders and three attackers,
But in this version, if we put the other knight on f3, we can't go knight b3 because we get
forked,
So technically, you can defend the pawn with queen to a4, but it should make sense to you
that this is not in the spirit of the variation,
The queen is super awkward on this square,
It's not doing anything,
And this is just not how you want to play this line,
Now you might say, well, what's the big problem?
Why can't we just take on c5?
And if you're familiar with basic positional concepts, it should make sense that breaking
up your pawn chain like that is, from a strategic standpoint, very much undesirable,
And what can happen is that you end up losing the e5 pawn without a lot of compensation,
So there is a line here where white plays queen e2, the only way to defend these two
pawns, and black drops the queen back to c7,
And it's already very, very difficult for white to protect this pawn,
In fact, the only move here that allows white to keep this pawn under control is knight
to b3, counterattacking the bishop,
Black drops the bishop back, and white brings the bishop to f4,
But here, black has a very, very nasty resource that is based on the undefended nature of
this bishop, and that is the move f6, very common idea in the French,
And you might get excited by the look of e takes f6, but unfortunately, this sacrifice
is unsound,
As tempting as it looks, after king f8, black is simply winning,
And the reason black is winning is because white has no pieces in the attack,
This square is covered by the knight, d6 is covered by the queen,
White has no follow up to the attack, literally,
There's just nothing,
fg7, king g7, black is like one step away from consolidating, and white can essentially
resign,
So here, white can play in a more resilient manner, but you have to be ready to lose the
e5 pawn, and that's essentially no fun,
So that's the reason why you have to be okay with sacking the pawn, and the way to do that
is by castling king side,
So after queen b6, the main move is to castle king side,
Black, of course, takes the pawn in the vast majority of cases,
Blah, blah, blah, blah, takes, takes, takes, takes,
Now the knight from d2 jumps into the game with knight to f3, hits the queen, protects
the pawn,
The queen moves back to b6, this is the main line,
Now the modern engines have come up with a really nice way of playing this line with
white,
So traditionally, the main move was queen to a4, trying to exert some pressure on this
knight,
But recently, Stockfish came up with, I think, a much cooler idea, which is to play a3,
And the idea of a3 is quite simple,
Let's say the black develops his bishop with bishop to e7,
First of all, a3 discourages black from developing the bishop to c5, because this runs right
into b4,
So typically black develops the bishop to e7 in the French, and now the point is that
white has the move bishop to e3,
This is an important idea to understand,
Now what happens if black plays queen takes b2, who can tell me?
Why is the move a3 necessary?
This is like my analysis from pretty recently, so you'll get an inside perspective of what
I myself play against the French,
Hopefully you'll like these ideas,
Yeah, so of course you play bishop d4, and the queen is trapped,
So why was a3 necessary?
Because it covers the b4 square, otherwise black would be able to evacuate via b4,
So in this situation, black cannot take on b2, cannot block with a knight because of
b4, and so black must either satisfy himself with bishop to c5, which is in general a very
undesirable move strategically in the French,
And the reason why is that now the g5 square is uncovered,
Now you might be like, g5 square is uncovered, why is that important?
The reason it's important is because after a move like bishop to d2, which by the way
is far from a bad move,
Let me just pull up my file just a moment,
What can you notice in the event the black castles kingside?
Well with the g5 square uncovered, the Greek gift sacrifice is now possible,
After king takes h7, knight g5, it's a classic Greek gift, and it's a terrible version for
black because all of his pieces are scattered about on the queenside,
So after bishop to c5, I actually think bishop d2 is the best move, and it is the best move
according to the engine,
Black has no good moves, the bishop on c5 is stuck, and the Greek gift sacrifice works
really, really nicely in this version,
The line goes on, black plays king to g6 here, white delivers a check on c2, forces black
to play a5, and after ef6, king f6, I won't bore you with the crazy details of this line,
but after queen h7, white has a massive attack, the rook is coming to e1, there's a million
mate threats, and this is essentially unplayable for black from a practical standpoint,
So hopefully that makes sense,
That's why bishop c5 isn't good,
So black essentially has to resort to playing queen back to d8, which is super passive,
and now rather than trying to checkmate black in one go, the best approach here is just
to play quiet, simple positional chess,
You start by playing rook to e1, just like solidifying your control over the center,
typically black like castles kingside, now it's a great idea to bring your queen out
to c2 and force a weakening move like h6, and now the engine likes rook a to d1, bringing
the rest of the pieces into the center, and just look at black's position and how hard
it is to play,
And one of the more beautiful ideas is if black tries to develop his queenside with
b6, white already has a winning idea,
Why did we induce the move h6?
Why is that a weakening move?
Well, this is an idea that you should be familiar with,
Who can tell me how white sets up an unstoppable threat of basically checkmate on the kingside?
This is a really, really cool move, really cool move,
So it's not g4, because g4 weakens white's own kingside,
There is a much more effective way of exploiting this hook,
Not bishop h7, rook d4, it's a retreating move,
Yeah, so like the move you want to play is bishop h6, but if you play it too quickly,
you don't have a follow up,
So how do we ensure that there's a follow up?
Yeah, queen c1,
Best move is queen c1, because you're also keeping an eye on the c file,
And if black plays, let's say bishop b7, then this move already works like a charm,
Definitely something to file away into your like mental directory of tactical ideas,
Like this position is already over, black has to try f5, and you want to pass on it,
Black has to take with the knight, and here I think the fastest engine checkmate is to
bring the rook up to e5 and then over to g5,
And again, notice that if black tries to escape, he gets checkmated in one move on g6,
So after queen c1, black can essentially resign,
Bishop h6 is completely unstoppable,
The line I analyzed was knight c5, and even here you can play bishop takes h6,
You actually don't need the light squared bishop, which is kind of cool,
It shows you how abundant white's tactical ideas are,
You don't need your light squared bishop, because here this is plenty, plenty sufficient,
And one really, really pretty idea is, let's say bishop to d7,
The best way to win is to go knight g5 and then rook g3, and rook takes g5 is unstoppable,
If black plays f6, there's a check, and there's a mate on h3,
So just one of many, many lines that show you the tactical potential in white's position
in this line,
So this is partially why I recommend the taros, because it really helps you develop your tactical
abilities,
So after queen b6, the new move is a3, and I really think a3 poses major, major problem
for black in this line,
Of course, knight c5 is never scary, because you can just drop the bishop back to c2, and
then your knight can come out to g5, your queen to h5, this is even worse for black,
And the knight can be always chased away with the move b4,
Sometimes French players like to go like this, they go knight c5 and a5, but here knight
to g5 strikes at the exposed king side, and if h6, just watch how quickly the attack turns
decisive,
You go queen h5, and if black plays g6, the move should be totally automatic to you,
If it takes g6, it's like all completely automatic,
But an instructive application of the theme I mentioned at the end of our game comes in
this position,
What do you think is white's best move?
What do you think is white's best move here?
What is the winning move?
Yeah, you don't go for mate, so a lot of newer players, they might sit there and, what about
this check?
Well, this check doesn't do anything,
The winning move is just knight f7, the freaking rook is trapped,
Literally the rook is trapped,
We've only sacrificed one minor piece, and we've gotten two pawns for it,
Well, I guess one pawn, because we were a pawn down,
The rook cannot be defended,
We're just going to be an exchange up,
If black counterattacks the rook, big deal, we just go rook b1,
So a very, very important takeaway from this game is that a lot of these attacks, they
don't actually conclude in checkmate, they conclude in the gain of material,
And if black plays queen c7, there's another classic idea, knight f7, queen f7, and bishop
g6 pins the queen,
So I could analyze this for several more hours, but it was important to me to demonstrate
what to do after queen to b6,
Our opponent chose the sort of second main line, bishop e7, and here there's only one
other variation that I want to explore in depth,
And once again, I will reveal some of my like deeply held opening secrets, and that is the
move g5,
So there was a point at which this line was considered to be essentially the refutation
of the knight f3 variation,
And if you're a French player, you know, you should be aware of this incredibly scary idea
of playing g5,
And what makes this idea scary is that black just wants to go g4,
There are some versions in which like this move literally traps the knight,
But of course, the larger point is to throw the knight off of f3, which releases white's
control over the d4 pawn,
So if white handles this in cautiously, then white's entire center can collapse,
If white plays h3, this often exacerbates the problem, because now g4 will come and
potentially open up the h file, and that's the last thing you want, okay?
So when I faced this line for the first time about 15 years ago, I tried something interesting,
After h5, I said, I'm going to stop the progress of black's pawns by playing g4,
And in response to this, my opponent applied one of the most beautiful ideas that have
ever been played against me in the French,
Here's what happened in that game,
My opponent, whose name was Abhijit Gupta, Indian Grandmaster, we got this position,
And let me verify that this was the exact position we had in the game,
And it was only after that game that I basically like went back to the drawing board and developed
a really good system against g5, because I got smashed,
So let me double check,
Okay, it was a slightly different position,
It was actually this position, except black's bishop was still on, oh, just a moment,
It was a slightly different variation, but I'm pretty sure that this idea can be applied
here,
Basically, what black does is he plays queen b6,
Now sacrificing the pawn here makes a lot less sense, because white's pawn is on g4
and the king is so weak,
So the only thing that white can do is play queen a4, and here the idea still applies,
My opponent, in a very similar position, played the move a6,
Now who can tell me what the heck the idea of this move is?
The position that we actually reached was really, really similar,
It was this exact position, but black's bishop was still on f8, in other words,
Yeah, queen to a7 and b5,
And it turns out that white's pawn on d4 collapses, because b5 is unstoppable,
You're going to lose d4, and then you're going to lose d5, and you're going to lose the game,
This is just crushing, a crushing idea,
My opponent carried this idea out and won the game,
So that's when I realized that you never, never, never want to meet this by playing
h3 and g4, because this weakens your king side way too much,
So instead, I came back and I developed an idea that I still think is very strong, and
that is the move queen to e2, which is actually, I think, a brilliant idea,
It's still not a very common move, so you're still likely to catch a lot of players by
surprise with this move,
Now first of all, let's understand what happens if black plays g4,
So obviously, you drop the knight back to e1, and you might look at this and say, well,
I don't get it,
Doesn't this just help black collapse our center?
Well, the caveat is that the g4 pawn is now hanging,
And if black takes on d4, we recapture on g4, and this is a terrible version for black,
because although black has succeeded in, essentially, exploding our center, black now has massive
fatal weaknesses on the king side, because the queen is coming to g7,
After knight to c6, the queen literally dives into g7, forces rook f8, and the e5 pawn
is very easy to defend,
We can do it by playing knight d to f3,
Very important to put this knight on f3 to open up the diagonal for your dark squared
bishop,
Black is busted here, completely and utterly and totally busted,
Just look at black's position,
Black can't move,
Typically, people play knight c5, and you can just drop the bishop into h6, and then
take on h7, and the rook is going to be trapped, so this is over,
But here's the secondary idea of queen e2,
Let's say that black plays the move h5, which is what most people end up playing against
queen e2,
Now, what is the idea of h5?
Who can tell me why?
What does this move threaten?
Why can't white just do anything?
This is what helps you understand white's response to this move,
Let's say white plays a random move, like a3,
It doesn't threaten h4,
It threatens g4, because now the pawn is protected,
Now the pawn is protected, so if we go down this line, you can't take on g4 anymore,
But now we understand the secondary idea of queen e2,
You play the move queen to e3, and you use the queen to defend the d4 pawn,
Typically, black excitedly plays g4, and this queen looks like a terrible piece, because
it can be chased with bishop to g5,
I've literally had this against GMs,
This is already almost losing for black, because here you pull out your third trump card, and
that's the f pawn,
You play f4, and if black takes on Passant, then you play queen takes f3, and the attack
on the f7 pawn becomes completely and totally decisive,
anyone can be put to use guarding the d4 pawn in the most harmonious way imaginable,
Black has no more way to put pressure on d4,
You have a retreating square for the bishop, so this is never scary,
And white just has long-term massive pressure on f7,
Black's position is super cramped, et cetera, et cetera,
So if black plays queen to b6, once again, you can drive the knight up to c2, and now
black no longer has bishop g5, and the plan here is just to push the f pawn all the way
up to f5 and break down black's pawn chain and checkmate black on the king side,
So this is my prep and a nutshell,
This will win you a lot of games, so you're welcome,
Now, mostly this is directed at higher-rated players, like 2,000 plus,
So if you're a newer player and you're watching this, please don't be annoyed,
Just try to extract the general takeaways from these ideas,
The last thing I'll say is that after queen e2, if black plays queen to b6, if black plays
queen to b6, then you can already take on c5,
And the difference between this version of dc and the version that I discouraged you
from playing earlier, like, for instance, in the early version of queen b6, the pawn
on e5 lacks sufficient defenders,
And it's very important when you're particularly at a higher-rated level to discern differences
between one version of events and another,
If we compare that to the version here, the pawn on e5 is now much better defended,
So the move bishop takes e5, it no longer comes with tempo,
And what can we use this tempo to do?
Well, we can use this tempo to drive the b pawn all the way up to b5, force the knight
off of c6, and in that way, we can force black to relinquish any remaining pressure on the
e5 pawn,
And black's position is completely in shambles,
Like, this is just awful for black,
Knight a5, we can go knight b3, open up the bishop, and black is collapsing on all sides
here,
So that's g5 in a nutshell,
Let's transition to our opponent's move, which is a5,
So a5, you can do your own research here,
I think a4 is a very simple move that you can play largely without too much preparation,
And so that's the reason why I played it,
Okay, so our opponent follows up with c takes d4,
Once again, if black plays queen to b6 here, then again, we can already play the move dc,
and we have sufficient resources with which we can defend the e5 pawn,
I had this over the board once, and I won that game pretty convincingly,
You play bishop c2,
And if black returns to d7, big frickin' deal,
You can just go rook e1, and you have just enough defenders to make sure that this pawn
is safely protected,
Now let's see who paid attention to the game continuation,
Let's say that in this position, black castles kingside,
Well, a great move in this position would be the exact move that we played in the game,
the exact maneuver,
We could go knight f1 and knight g3,
Or we could play this more positionally, and we could pay a visit to the d4 square, which
is now a really nice outpost for white's knights,
White is better on both sides of the board,
You have b5, you have the diagonal, you have attacking chances,
This is a terrible version for black,
And so cd is like the more natural way to continue here,
Hopefully everything is making sense,
Knight b4,
Now, I'm checking reference, and I see that this position occurred over 150 times,
And there was a famous game, oh crap, I actually think I had it,
Yeah, I had a very similar position against Rosenthalis,
But the highest rated game in this position was Adams against Karawana from 2009,
So Mickey Adams had this with white against Fabi in 2009, and Adams won,
And interestingly, Adams actually played this a lot more positionally,
Adams, or sorry, Karawana played knight b4,
Karawana played the immediate knight to b4,
And in response to this move, Adams actually did play bishop to b5, and he played a brilliant
positional game, which you can look up on your own,
But according to the engine, instead of bishop to b5, bishop to b1 is a completely viable
positional alternative,
But there's a really interesting subtlety,
And based on this subtlety, I actually think that castle and king side is a big mistake
for black,
This is pretty mind expanding stuff,
Here's the difference,
After castle's king side, rookie one night before bishop b1, the king has already committed
to the king side,
And it's already committed to a lifetime of misery because of our pressure on h7,
But after the immediate night before, after bishop b1, black doesn't have to commit to
castle and king side, and believe it or not, the king in the center is much safer in this
particular position than it would be on the king side,
So by comparison, bishop b1 is a lot less effective here,
Black can play b6,
And if we try to do the same thing that we did in the game, if we play rookie one, bishop
to a6, 50 games in the database here,
And if we play knight f1, black can essentially save a tempo on castle and king side and immediately
go for the queen side pressure with rook to c8,
So this has occurred many, many times in top level games,
And if white plays knight to g3, here is the crux of this difference,
Black has a resource in this position that he would not have if the black king were already
castled king side,
It's a pretty crazy looking move, but it should make a lot of sense if you're familiar with
one of the chief drawbacks of the knight placement on g3,
According to the engine, white is still better after this move, but at least it keeps practical
chances for black,
And it is the move h7 to h5,
Were black castled, this move would be impossible because that would be unprotected,
Black plays h5,
Black wants to drive this knight out of g3,
But more importantly, black wants to prevent the knight from jumping into h5,
And the top engine move here is one that we made in the game,
And that is the move rook a1 to a3, preparing to contest the c-file with rook c3,
This has still occurred in the game,
Now the engine recommends g5, opening up the familiar king side attack, and the position
is crazy,
Like if you analyze with the computer here, the lines are absolutely crazy,
It's giving an edge to white, but obviously both sides have ample chances here,
And so that is why Michael Adams, as well as many others, decided to go bishop b5, and
then maneuvering the knight from b1 to c3 with a clear positional advantage,
White is still better here, but obviously with bishop b5, white is basically playing
on the queen side rather than on the king side,
But after castles king side, rook e1, knight e4, here bishop b1 is a no-brainer because
the king is now stuck on the king side, and we're setting up a massive king side attack,
So this is what it really comes down to,
It's these small subtleties, these move orders, and they are what start to decide the game
at this level,
It may sound totally insignificant, but I think after bishop b1, black is borderline
lost from a human perspective just because white's attack is so ridiculously strong,
So our opponent played very sensibly, like knight b8 makes perfect sense,
We played knight f1, completing the standard maneuver,
The engine eval here is already plus two and a half, just because black has no play on
the queen side, whereas we are completely in position for a decisive king side attack,
And there is still a game in the database here,
Black was 23-51, and white was 26-39, Ukrainian grandmaster,
So in that game, black played the miserable move g6,
Oh, this is sexy,
And white missed the top engine move, which is still to play knight h5,
And if black takes, knight to g5,
Oh, look at this,
Bishop takes g5,
You sack two knights in a row,
Now you play queen takes h5,
You hit the bishop, hit the pawn,
Black has to go here,
And now who can find the brilliant winning move?
You already know this idea,
It's time to apply it,
White to play and win,
You know, chess is just amazing,
It's a quiet move,
It's rook to a3, time to involve the rook,
Now what does rook a3 do in this exact situation?
Well, let's say black continues chomping on the pawns,
Well, you just go rook g3,
And black just doesn't have sufficient defensive forces to hold off the king side,
The threat is queen takes h6 as well as bishop takes g5,
The game is over,
That's it,
This would have been the fastest way to win,
If black does not take the knight on h5, if black does not take the knight on h5, then
well, then we win by either sticking the knight on f6 or playing bishop to h6,
Black has no moves here,
So let's say black makes a waiting move, bishop d7,
Again, the engine likes to involve the rook, rook to a3, rook to c8, for example,
And now h4 is actually a great move, setting up a stronghold on g5 for the other knight,
So we literally just play with this knight hanging,
And the moment black takes, we apply our standard idea with knight to g5,
Just to show you the attacking potential that white's pieces possess here,
I think our opponent played a better defensive move than the 2300 did,
I think g6 is just essentially a losing move,
And yeah, so h4 is not mandatory,
But I wanted to play this move because it illustrates white's attacking potential,
So in response to bishop takes h4, I think the simplest thing to do would be to play
knight h5,
Just sticking the knight on like the ideal attacking square and setting up the threat
of knight takes g7, as well as rook to a3,
So the engine line here is g6,
We just play knight takes h4, queen h4, we give a check on f6, and we win the game because
the bishop hangs,
And we can also simply trap the queen with a move like g3,
Or the top engine move is rook to a3, again, lifting the rook up to h3,
And here we have this beautiful move, just winning everything because this is checkmate,
So in response to knight h5, g6 is literally never possible,
So let's say black withdraws the bishop back to e7,
Well, you will never guess what the top engine move is here, right?
Once you're familiar with the ideas, you can apply them over and over and over again,
And who would have known that a4 is a move played not just to prevent black from playing
a4, but also to open up the pathway for the rook to join the attack via a3,
White plays rook a3,
Black has no moves,
Again, let's say the black just continues accumulating on the king side, bang,
Knight g7, king g7, and now a very common follow-up is to play either knight h2 and
open up the pathway for the queen, or just drive the queen up to h6 with a completely
decisive attack,
Check,
Let's say that the king tries to run to the center,
We just go knight g5, check,
We take back with the bishop, and it's very obvious where this is going and not in a favorable
direction for black, queen to b6, queen h5, check, and rook g3, et cetera,
This is easily, easily winning,
Just rook h3, and black has no pieces on the king side,
So one of the sub-themes of this game is not all attacks are the same,
And when you hear the word attack, you often associate it with a lightning series of moves
where every move has to be a sacrifice,
Many times when you're attacking, you can afford to play slowly because black has nothing
going for him on the other side of the board,
So a lot of attacks have to be conducted in this very slow or relatively slow and deliberate
way,
And the buildup to the sacrifice is the stage of attack that's not talked about enough,
When you're solving exercises or you're reading books, they usually talk about the final
stage,
That's like the stage which begins with this move,
But the stage that's not talked about enough is the one that involves moves like h4 and
knight h5 and rook a3,
Remember that those buildup moves are an integral part of every attack, particularly attacks
that involve this many moving parts,
So our opponent played f6, which I think relatively is maybe even the best resource we take on
f6, and now a critical part of the game where we transition from attacking play to positional
play with bishop to g5,
So that's a long speech, but hopefully this helps you understand how white's attack actually
works,
And once again, in response to bishop takes g5, we have the Greek gift sacrifice,
So notice how we're like seamlessly weaving between positional play and tactical play
based on what black is doing,
So if bishop g5, we deliver a game-winning tactic with bishop h7,
Our opponent played queen c7, and here we continue playing positionally with rook to
a3, our goal to secure complete control of the e5 square,
Now if black had played h6 and tried to force things, yeah, we would have taken on f6,
And then we could have thrown in the move knight h5 because it doesn't hurt,
And then we could have continued by dominating the e5 square with knight e5,
And the attack flows naturally, now we stick a rook on e5, the other rook can come into
g3, and we can kind of go back to deciding the game via attack,
So h6 is never scary,
Our opponent decided to keep the tension, and the rest of the game I think is pretty
much natural,
We go rook e3,
I think the engine always finds ways that the defending side can survive for longer,
but hopefully the course of the game was able to show you just how difficult it is for black
to play a position like this,
Our opponent played queen d6, and now we found the perfect opportunity to play knight h5,
Our opponent played king h8, and now the other knight comes into e5,
And already the game is over, because once again, if knight e5, then we play d5,
If black takes the bishop on g5, then the open h-file only serves to further illustrate
the hopelessness of black's position,
In response to knight takes e5, we can again switch from positional to tactical gear,
We can take with the pawn voluntarily, and the reason is to garner a tempo that we can
use to stick the knight on f6,
And just look at this,
gf6, simply ef6, pre-moving queen h5, and the game is over,
Just look at black's pathetic game, rook f7, queen h5, rook f8, g6 is I think a simple
way to end the game,
So that's another one of the sub-themes of this game, which is like, not assuming that
you're playing with one mode, right?
You're not always playing positionally or tactically,
You could basically be doing both at the same time, and you're deciding on a mode based
on how your opponent is reacting,
But here we're harnessing both our positional advantages, like i,e, our control over the
key central square, as well as our preponderance of pieces on the king side,
And this kind of play is incredibly, incredibly powerful,
And we conclude the game with a simple sacrifice, knight takes g7, followed by queen h5, and
this is already forced mate,
According to the engine, the fastest mate would have been queen h6 check, and now bishop
f6, but who cares?
This technically is the engine way to mate, but I think we found a completely satisfactory
way to win the game,
There was no doubt about the result,
But according to the engine, queen h6 check, and bishop f6 is fastest, because here rook
g3 is mate, and if black gives away the rook, then we play ef,
I calculated to this position and forgot that we have a check on g3, followed by rook g7,
and this is just mate on the spot,
So this would be the fastest way to win the game, but we threw in the immediate check,
And the only important line here was to understand that king takes f6 gets check mated with queen
h5, again notice the power of the pawn on h4, followed by rook to f3,
And that's another cool takeaway from this game, I think most people when they think
about the use of pawns in attacking, they think of pawn storms,
So when you see the move h4 as a less experienced player, you might think that the only idea
is just to run the pawn up to h6, and to shatter black's pawn formation,
And that is a viable use of pawns in attacking, but there is a second use, which is to basically
advance pawns and use them as pedestals on which you can put your pieces,
Like the pawn can be a very powerful supporting piece, which can open doors for your minor
pieces to jump into squares that they otherwise couldn't access,
And that's ultimately what ended up happening in the game, or what could have ended up happening
if black had played king takes f6,
As it stood, like we just played rook c3, then we take the knight, and then we mate
with queen to g6, or platform is a better term I think,
So int90 asks, why not the immediate rook c3 after knight c2, well because that blunders
the pawn on f2, and then the rook on e1,
This would be the best way to complicate the game, white is still winning after bishop
takes c2, this just illustrates how bad it is for black,
You can literally blunder this pawn with check and then the rook, and you're still winning,
But why allow any of that, right?
So the e5 pawn, a platform for the bishop to jump into f6,
Hopefully that wasn't too rambly,
Just as a quick summary, we didn't talk much about the other options in this position for
black,
The main one is c5, and I have a feeling that we're still going to face this in a later
game in the speedrun,
Here we focused on the second main line,
Now there are some sidelines along the way that we didn't talk about, so I showed you
some of my preparation after queen to b6, the bottom line is that you are ready and
willing to sacrifice the pawn on d4,
And the second line we focused on is this very sharp line with g5,
And in response to g5, queen e2 is a very very powerful weapon to have up your sleeve,
Of course this merely scratches the surface, like at one point g6 was considered to be
the best move in the position, and I still believe that g6 is probably black's best bet
to get dynamic equality, this is something we'll leave for a separate analysis,
Also interesting is the immediate a5,
Also a line that was very very popular at some point, but most intermediate players
I think are still going to face bishop e7 most of the time, and in this position we
also didn't talk about castle's king side, to which you respond rook e1, and again this
idea knight f1 knight g3 is kind of white's main follow up, but hopefully you found the
analysis to be semi enlightening,
That concludes the speedrun game for today, if you're watching on youtube you can see
how much more complicated the games are becoming, it's becoming harder for me to explain everything
concisely and hopefully I'm doing a decent job of it, but yeah the games are becoming
a lot more variation heavy, there's a lot more concepts involved, but that's called
chess progression, that's why it's hard to improve, because to win at this level you
need to have command of like many many different concepts that you display every single game,
From opening theory knowledge, to knowledge of when to sacrifice, to knowledge of how
to play simultaneously attacking chess, while also exploiting positional factors, that's
just part of the process of chess improvement, and I'm just doing my best to highlight some
of these skills and to show you how I'm able to apply them consistently to win games,
So on that note we're going to end for today folks, I'm exhausted, I am going to pass the
stream off, to whom am I going to pass it off, that's the big question, I'm going to
pass it off to Zephcat, been a while since we raided Zephcat, let's do that now, thank
you everybody for hanging out and for paying attention during the speedruns, it really
really helps to have a captive audience, hope you enjoyed the chess, thanks again for all
the support and the subs for those who donated, one quick note, if you're new to this channel
you like what I do, you want to support me, easiest way to do that is to subscribe on
my YouTube channel, the goal is to reach 500k subs by the end of 2023, it's not going to
happen but the best chance is for people to subscribe if you like my content and you want
more of the same, so thanks everybody,